g7
uh take away uh summer take aways the
u.s is back on top the queen cut accord
with a sword
and world's leaders uh world leaders
promised 1 billion
1 billion covet 19 doses this is
business insider story uh
let's see how we want to do this which
one do you want to go through because
there's a lot of stories here just kind
of share your thoughts on what you
thought about it i like the thought on
russia
the thought on russia which one is that
just you know how biden is in europe now
right and he talks a good game when he's
in front of these other leaders
just what is he going to do with russia
i just think
putin would dominate him in a one-on-one
meeting that is just
you know you couldn't even measure how
much dominance he would have i think i
think biden's afraid of him
i think he talks a really tough game
when he's not around him but you know we
all
agree that cyber security is one of the
biggest issues we face right now
the threats are coming from russia they
are the ones doing it
and what's a company supposed to do
their only option is to pay the ransom
right and get things going again i mean
we don't even know a fraction of the
amount of cyber attacks that are going
on i mean
they said there was like 65 000 last
year man we hear about one
every other week but they're constantly
happening he has to stand up
at some point and address this with him
and i just don't think he's got the guts
i don't i think
because of hunter he has compromised joe
biden in so many different ways
on a world stage that he's just he's
unable to i don't think he wants to and
i think he's unable to
so i think that is such a pressing issue
that we'll never get to the bottom of
because he's not going to do anything
i think the the key thing that is
happening um
with the g7 um and it comes down to you
talked about policies
and and basically different perspectives
on how
things are operating i think for sure
and this isn't a knock on trump but his
whole brand was unilateralism america
first i got this i alone
can fix this whereas biden or the
democratic party they are more about
multilateralism they believe in the
power of multiple countries
i.e the g7 the g8 or the g20 working
together
in cooperation to solve big problems we
just dealt with the biggest problem in
the last hundred years
the coronavirus and now there this is
the importance of working with your
allies i think there's a
um a famous to quote my friend kai over
here his hero winston churchill
the only thing worse than fighting with
your allies is fighting without them
right winston churchill so right now we
are we are working with our allies
uk france japan germany g7 countries
to work together to figure out what the
hell is going on in this world and
coalescing behind an anti-china and even
an
anti-russian uh opposition because
at this point the world needs to unify
against what the hell
china did or what it's doing and make no
mistake about it
did you see the interview with um i
believe his name is kier simmons
uh with he interviewed putin a couple
days ago did you see that interview
he pressed putin pretty hard um putin
would not
talk bad about china at all
he's basically saying why are you trying
to make me say bad things about china
we're working together with china so you
talked about uh
cyber warfare and ransomware and
everything that's going like that that
is the new modern warfare
and who are the biggest culprits in that
for sure russia for sure
china so i think the world needs to come
together and call out
bad actors for what they are you know
this is the time for democracies to
stand up united states uk france germany
modern day democracies to go against
authoritarian dictators
of putin and she who are working
together and this is the world against
the bad actors so i think
good things will come from this g7 and
whether you're
uh a biden fan or not you should not be
rooting for
putin in this instance okay root for
biden
to deal to tell basically putin stop
[ __ ] with the united states here or
we're going to come after you i don't
think they came out of it anymore line
though there's a lot of friction between
even these seven leaders as far as what
to do with china
i mean that's that's part of the the
story the the narrative of what happened
at g7 is like behind the closed doors
they weren't agreeing on anything
there is a uh uh he said what did what
did putin say to china it says on russia
biden and uh
biden said u.s relations with moscow
have reached a low point
low point what does that mean low point
i mean low point it wasn't low
just a couple of years ago why is it a
local and then you follow that up by
saying they're at their lowest point
that they've been in a very very long
time but we don't want conflict with
russia that's what he said well stop
hacking everything and stop putting uh
viruses on everything and maybe we'll
have a better relationship
it's a two-way street like like my mom
used to always say in order to be a
friend
in order to have a friend you need to be
a friend so here we are trying to
have good relations with russia but
everything in the news is
russians russian hackers did this
russian did this russia think
putin is sitting there
weighing out which ally is more
important and necessary to him china or
iran and if yes he is
who is more important to russia without
even a question tell me why
china versus iran no no i'm sorry my
apologies china versus us who is more
important of an ally china or iran well
china or u.s china u.s is not an ally
with russia and they're clearly aligning
with china
i get that but what i'm asking you is is
putin sitting there saying
i better be careful you know because he
doesn't think u.s is going to be that
powerful
nation as it once was i better start
kind of stepping back and kind of making
sure that my
relationship with china is strong
because they're neighbors they're down
the street
i know so they're neighbors but i better
be better with china than i am with u.s
well he came out and said that he is
working on
relationships with china i mean he came
out which is not denied important to him
do you believe china
without a doubt i think china's more
important to russia than u.s is
yeah probably because i don't think he i
think each day that goes by i think the
threat
of the u.s is minimized in his mind and
he's definitely
calculating every possible move that he
could make that would be my question if
i'm him i would be looking at that
if i'm him wondering which one of those
two relationships it's interesting
yeah i mean even just look at the the
the from the rest of the
uh of the article some of the big things
that the when i talked about
multilateralism these countries and
these western democracies
working together key issues china
vaccines covet
we talk about this global minimum tax of
15 believe me they're working on that
climate change these are big issues that
major companies
major countries have to work together on
you can't go at these types of things
alone so pat you were getting at the
fact that if he looks at
china as a bigger threat he might soften
on the us and look to a line in a few
more ways
no no no just the other way like like if
he sees
china is about to be a bigger threat to
the world and take over u.s
it is more necessary for him to have a
better working relationship with china
than it is with the us
so here's one two you know how in life
you you have kids and you have wife
which relationship matters more to you i
i don't think i should answer them no no
that's actually a real question
i think which relationship if you have a
wife and kids i mean again i'm not
married no kids but i hear every single
one of my friends basically say the most
important thing
are my kids that's what i hear every
parent say
i can find a new wife i can find a new
husband i don't i love my kids i don't
this is that the question you're at
you're not
what i'm asking is which one is more
important for you to have a better
relationship with
your wife oh your wife your wife your
relationship
you know i'm talking about who it's more
important not who is your
wife's not your blood but your kid is
your blood but you made the kid with the
wife right so you have to realize that
part of it
but uh you know he's he's weighing out
which relationship's more important
right now to him and i think uh
for the time being he's probably sitting
there saying we better not go through
the whole process of us always being
number one we kind of u.s is getting
weaker maybe not as strong as china was
china's getting right now china's making
a lot of progress we may want to kind of
consider being lighter on china than u.s
which is scary because if they're
allies that's it they already are out
guys
this is why this is why i'm banking on
india this is why i believe india is a
because if india china and russia team
up
game over if india china and let's just
say somebody gets elected in india
that hates the us and likes more with
china and russia and their bot
it's over if india gets bought out in
the next 10 years it's game over
that's not how it's telling me i'm just
standing well yeah that's not happening
meaning i
i think there's some commonality here
with democratic countries
and autocratic countries they there's
like-minded thinking
with china and russia and iran and north
korea
they're like-minded thinkers just like
in democratic countries and western
democratic
civilizations united states france
basically europe india included
australia included
there's like-minded thinking there so of
course
putin and she are going to see
eye-to-eye on things just like a biden
and merkel are going to see eye to eye
on things and macro
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye